hey everybody seven I'm a little bit
sick today but I'm super excited to
announce that this friday on
entrepreneurs youtube channel i'm going
to be doing a live free Q&A session with
you to talk about how to build a
community around your content when i
first start on my youtube channel it was
to give back to help others to
contribute to the entrepreneur world
they didn't want people to struggle in
the same way that I struggled when i
first started my business and it's grown
to be one of the most important areas of
my business we're now I'm getting you
know up to thousands of subscribers a
day we're getting 200 comments a day on
the channel the community is what feeds
me it's what fuels me I start my day
with answering questions and comments
from the community every day because I'm
making these videos for you guys and so
that community love has led me to be
able to create six-figure deals with
brands to get book deals to grow a
business to hire a team and it's worked
out really well for me and I want to be
able to give back and teach and help you
guys to do the same thing because I know
you have a message you have something
powerful that's in you that you want to
share and it's a fantastic way to build
up awareness to build a brand and to get
a lot of deals coming to you I haven't
done any marketing of my videos I
haven't gone out and tried to go out and
get brands everything has been in coming
to me because of the content that I'm
produce in the community that I've built
and you know I call a belief nation it's
a loyal group of people who are now
spending part of their day every day
coming back and checking out that
channel and that's a big responsibility
for me and and I think that's the most
important part is that is having an
impact on people's lives and so I want
to be able to share that with you I want
you to be able to do something similar i
want you to tap into your voice and
create content that people care about I
want to answer any questions that you
have about YouTube and how to build
successful brand on the platform you
have me for one hour totally free we're
looking at this friday from three
o'clock to four o'clock p.m. eastern
it's not going to be on my channel it's
going to be
entrepreneurs channel and I put the link
in the description below I hope to see
you there i hope i'm better by then i'm
taking medication just came out from the
doctor today and so I'm excited to be at
a hundred percent to give it to you guys
so I hope you'll join me i'm looking
forward to answer your questions thank
you guys continue to believe and i'll
see you there